Graf's 0.04 on the number line so here
we have this number line that goes from
zero to 0.1 or one tenth and between
zero and one tenth we have one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten equal
spaces so each of these spaces
represents one tenth of the distance is
one out of ten equal spaces or we could
say it is one tenth of this tenth is a
tenth of the way to one tenth
that's a little bit tricky maybe let's
pause and look at that visually and
think about what does a tenth of a tenth
really mean so here I have already drawn
a picture that's divided into ten equal
pieces and if we shade one of them then
we're shading one tenth this right here
is one tenth and this amount right here
is what the number line showed the whole
number line showed one tenth but then we
had divided that tenth into ten equal
pieces so if we split that ten into ten
equal pieces we're going to have
something like this so here again this
top row would represent the entire tenth
from the whole number line but each
little piece would be one of those one
tenth of that whole tenth or so this is
what each little piece on the number
line represents or we could say that's
one one hundredth a tenth of a tenth is
a 100 because when you divide ten into
ten equal pieces you're going to end up
with a hundred pieces so a tenth of a
tenth is 1/100 so looking back at the
number line now we know that this
distance a tenth of our tenth is 1/100
and we want to graph 0.04
well this 4 right here this 4 let's
think about place value the zeros and
the ones the next year on the tenth and
this 4 is in the hundredths so we could
call this 4
hundreds or even the fraction four
hundredths so if one of these lengths is
one hundredth and we want to go for
hundreds then we're going to need to go
four of these links one two three four
of these links would be four of the
hundredths or 0.04